[Musik]
digitalisierung macht das leben
einfacher keine frage aber was wenn
verborgene code das leben noch
ungerechter machen
das ich opfer von technischer oder
digitaler diskriminierung bin ist
einfach unfassbar für mich
er hoffte technik entwickelt die dann
diejenigen die ohnehin schon sozial
schwach sind noch stärker belastet
die daten sind auf jeden fall vom wissen
alter weißer männer geprägt aber nur in
dem sinne in dem unsere ganze
gesellschaft
von alten weißen männern geprägt ist
dass wir nämlich feststellen ist dass
wir zu nehmen den letzten jahren
bestimmte geschäftsmodelle haben die
sich etabliert haben die frei von den
werken sind die wir als gesellschaft
haben
diskriminierende ki in der medizin kann
natürlich zu falschen diagnostik und
therapie führen und letztendlich kann
natürlich es auch zum tod führen
was haben algorithmen mit unserem alltag
zu tun eigentlich mit allem ob wir
kredite bekommen einen job oder eine
wohnung aber auch mit unserer sicherheit
unserer gesundheit unseren
freundschaften und unseren gefühlen
algorithmen sollen unser leben einfacher
und bequemer machen frei von vorurteilen
ohne diskriminierung
aber stimmt das
wir sprechen mit menschen die
diskriminierung erfahren zuerst im
realen leben und jetzt auch in der
digitalen welt
vielleicht gibst du mir beispiele
[Musik]
wenn ich morgens aufstehe und gucken
meine die ems ist mache ich meistens
leider im bett und dann sehe oder höre
du fette schweigende mal ab du solltest
man sollte dich erstechen oder
also wirklich die bösen worte und sätze
dann möchte ich eigentlich sofort wieder
aufhören ich bin da war wo ich bin 42
mama an allererster stelle ich bin aber
auch klassische im kämpferin also man
findet mich in den sozialen medien unter
kurven raus
ich habe eine essstörung nämlich gehe
ich auch sehr offen und transparent auf
einem kanal umwelt ich glaube darüber
muss gesprochen werden ich wurde
wirklich aufs peres person beleidigt
wenn ich dann noch mit meiner r störung
im hallen möchte ich wurde als mutter
beleidigt dass ich als mutter versagt
hätte weil mein sohn der in den ich
einmal oder zweimal gezeigt habe und man
das so wie auch ein kleines bäuchlein
hätte
tanja ist sich sicher dass der hass
gegen sie von algorithmen begünstigt
wird bestätigt fühlt sie sich von
whistleblowerinnen frances horgen dem
herbst 2021 mit schweren vorwürfen gegen
ihren ehemaligen arbeitgeber facebook an
die öffentlichkeit gehen sie sagte unter
anderem die forschung von facebook
selbst zeige dass es am einfachsten ist
menschen zu inspirieren
so würden polarisierende inhalte sprich
hate speech begünstigt auch unserer
redaktion liegen die facebook papers vor
diese legen nahe dass die algorithmen
des us-unternehmens inhalte pushen die
menschen aufregen und interaktionen
aber erst mal zurück zu tun ja
sie ist der überzeugung dass menschen
die nicht der vermeintliche norm
entsprechen von den sozialen plattformen
benachteiligt werden es geht in den
sozialen medien immer oder auf den
sozialen apps immer um geld
also ist es im interesse der inhaber der
apps möglichst das auszuspielen womit
sie am meisten geld verdienen und das
sind nicht wenige mädchen und jungs
[Musik]
also ich glaube es gibt situation an die
ich mich erinnere wo wirklich die der
algorithmus auch wirklich fett feindlich
dann auch tatsächlich gewesen ist und
zwar habe ich einen lippenstift gelaunt
mit einem kosmetikunternehmen und ich
stand in shape wear und einem laser
bekleidet also man sagen vielleicht ein
bisschen von meinem ausschnitt und es
wurde dann als nacktheit betitelt wo
obwohl ich überhaupt nicht nackt war
oder eine freundin von mir hat das thema
bauchfett besprochen hat einmal ein foto
gezeigt wo sie eine high waist hose
anhat und dann hat sie die einfach ein
bisschen runter gezogen weil sich ihr
bauchfett das konnte man dann nicht
bewerben oder posten weil es stand er
drin nacktheit in klammern oder
bauchfett sichtbar also diskriminiert
instagram bauchfett von merkel wichtigen
menschen ein waschbrett bauch eines
mannes darf aber gepostet werden wir
konfrontieren meter mit diesen vorwürfen
eine sprecherin sagt
die annahme dass die sichtbarkeit von
beiträgen aufgrund von faktoren wie
körperlichen merkmalen beeinträchtigt
wird ist nicht korrekt
wir feiern die vielfalt auf instagram
und wir wollen ausschließlich erreichen
dass die zeit davon unserer plattform
durch unsere richtlinien sinn stiften
wertvoll und sicher für eine ist
als influenza hängt an jahreseinkommen
unmittelbar von ihrer präsenz auf den
sozialen plattformen ab ähnlich geht es
denn martens sie ist unternehmerin auch
für die vermarktung ihrer
naturkosmetikmarke für lockiges haar und
afro h nutzt sie digitale wege
gefällt grundsätzlich auf das wenn ich
konzentriere und einen schwarzen
menschen poste dass es nicht verbreitet
wird ich muss dazwischen immer einen
weißen menschen posten damit der
algorithmus greift und das ist jetzt
wirklich kein scherz dass es wirklich so
und dann hinterher muss ich dann gucken
was poste ich dann wenn ich dann wieder
in schwarzen menschen poster wird das
wieder gedrosselt also ich habe
tatsächlich lange darüber nachgedacht ob
ich wirklich darüber sprechen möchte
meistens frisst man das in sich hinein
ist frustriert und ich finde es wird
zeit dass man einfach damit nach außen
geht und sagt stopp ich werde
diskriminiert
ich gebe alles so wie auch ein anderer
weißer mensch und trotzdem werde mein
konzert nicht verbreitet können
algorithmen wirklich diskriminieren wenn
ja wie kommt das zustande
wie geht das was sind algorithmen
überhaupt zunächst mal werden
algorithmen von menschen geschrieben es
sind quasi anleitungen die dem computer
schritt für schritt sagen was er tun
soll um eine bestimmte aufgabe zu
bewältigen klingt wie ein kochrezept
im grunde ja nun ist es aber unmöglich
die reale welt mit ihren unzähligen
möglichkeiten und situationen in festen
regeln abzubilden an dem punkt werden
algorithmen entwickelt die selbst lernen
sie können in kurzer zeit viel
komplexere sachverhalte verarbeiten als
es ein mensch in einzelne vorschriften
gießen könnte das ist dann die
künstliche intelligenz oder
wie würden sie es erklären kennzahl abu
künstliche intelligenz ist die fähigkeit
eine maschine aus ganz vielen
informationen wissen zu generieren und
diese fähigkeit erlangt die maschine
anhand verschiedener methoden deswegen
sollte man sich das wirklich wie ein
werkzeugkasten vorstelle wo ganz viele
methoden sind jemand entweder einzeln
und annika oder in kombination nutzt ich
bin kein sei als jago ingenieure
elektrotechnikerin um genau zu sein um
seit ein paar jahre managerin im bereich
robotics und künstlicher intelligenz
die maschinen lernen von uns wie die
welt funktioniert
genauso wie unsere kinder ist tun die
kinder lernen dass beim beobachten sie
sehen was sie machen und wiederholen das
was sie tun und die maschinen lernens
aus den daten und das bekommt dann die
maschine zu trainieren die analysiert
diese daten erkennt muster aus den daten
und mit diesen mustern kann man
folgeprozesse steuern entscheidungen
treffen oder oder empfehlungen
aussprechen beim kaufen beim klicken
beim stöbern in den suchmaschinen wir
füttern die algorithmen mit unseren
daten die maschinen lernen also von
unserem verhalten im netz diesen vorgang
nennt man machine learning
ich bin juristin und professorin hier am
oxford internet institute an der
positiven oxford und ich beschäftige
mich mit den rechtlichen und ethischen
auswirkungen von neuen technologien und
im speziellen mit künstlicher
intelligenz und machine learning es gibt
keine situation wo man einen neutralen
datensatz bekommt einen neutralen
datensatz gibt es nur in einer perfekten
welt in utopia ich glaube tatsächlich
dass die algorithmen der spiegel
unsere gesellschaft ist
das heißt leider sehr oft mit technik
entwickelt die dann diejenigen die
ohnehin schon sozial schwach sind noch
stärker belastet und das ist leider sehr
oft der fall für frauen dass es leider
sehr auf der fall für nichtweiße
menschen und sehr sehr auf der fall für
leute aus der entwickler-community
klartext wer im realen leben betroffen
ist ist auch online nicht geschützt
beispiel suchmaschine wir alle kennen
google nutzen wir fast alle täglich mehr
als 70 prozent aller suchen im internet
laufen über diesen browser doch was
wenige wissen schon eine einfache
suchanfrage wird nicht neutral
ausgespielt das heißt sie wird eine
relevanz gefehlt hat doch wer bewertet
was relevant ist bei der antwort auf
diese frage können traditionelle
rollenbilder und vorurteile ins spiel
kommen
machen wir das verständlicher anhand
eines konkreten falls die medizinerin
özlem theorie ist maßgeblich für die
entwicklung des corona impfstoffs von
baltec mitverantwortlich klar oder der
google algorithmus jedoch unter schlug
zunächst ihre wichtige rolle als
forscherin bei der vorschau im suchfeld
wurde türe die als ehefrau von uhr sahin
angezeigt bei herrn sahin wurde dagegen
seinen job als bei ex-chef genannt
inzwischen hat google den titel ehefrau
entfernt aber es wird weiter lediglich
als ärzte betitelt
googles reaktion auf die kritik lautete
wir haben automatische systeme die
verhindern sollen dass ungenauigkeiten
auftreten diese systeme sind jedoch
nicht immer perfekt
das problem ist tatsächlich jenes das
sozusagen die hürden die frauen
überwältigen müssen nur drüber springen
müssen in der offline welt
dieselben sind diese dann online wieder
finden wir wissen dass das im
kreditwesen ähnlich eine rolle spielt er
hat zum beispiel probleme gehabt damit
wo kredite an männer mehr vergeben
worden sind als an frauen und wir wissen
dass wenige rhythmen eingesetzt werden
um zu entscheiden wer zu uni zugelassen
wird frauen auch benachteiligt sind das
heißt arbeitswelt finanzsektor
ausbildung all die dinge sind bereiche
wo frauen ganz besonders stark betroffen
sind heißt das am ende dass die hälfte
der weltbevölkerung wegen ihres
geschlechts von algorithmen
benachteiligt werden kann
genau das laut unsere expertinnen wird
es noch gravierender wenn eine frau
zusätzlich zum beispiel wegen herkunft
hautfarbe klasse oder sexuelle
orientierung diskriminiert wird
zurückzuziehen sie erzählt dass sie so
gut wie alle zwei wochen rassismus im
alltag erlebt es ist in dem moment zwar
frustrierend aber nicht ganz so weit da
direkt auch agieren kann runden spruch
zurückgehen kann anders ist dass man
digital rassismus da kann ich nichts
machen ich bin im ausgeliefert cem
erzählt von diversen situationen in
denen sie von technik auch analoge
benachteiligt wurde vom seifenspender
der über ihrer schwarzen hand nicht
auslöste von der automatik für die ihr
schwarzes gesicht nicht erkannte und für
sie nicht öffnete
zufall eher nicht denn bei ihrem weißen
lebenspartner klappte immer alles also
nach einem konzert wollten uns gerne
fotografieren lassen das war einer
unserer ersten dates oder dachten wir
wollen gerne diesen moment festhalten
und auch das gefühl was wir hatten
unheilig wäre es das erste mal zu sehen
und wir wollten uns fotografieren lassen
ein sind und dann gemeinsam bei ihm ging
dieser foto automat problemlos ich habe
mich rein gesetzt es ging nicht und das
war schon ein komisches gefühl weil ich
dachte ist das ding kaputt kann doch
nicht sein weil er war ja vorher dran
und er hat funktioniert ich habe ihnen
dann zu mir geholt und wie gesagt er ist
weiß und er musste sich dann auch
tatsächlich weiter nach vorne setzen und
ich musste mich von der seite mit meinem
handy an leuchten damit ich überhaupt
als punkt erfasst werde und erst dann
haben wir es hingekriegt dass dieser
fotoautomaten diese fotoautomaten
losgegangen ist und uns quasi gemeinsam
fotografiert hat und wenn man das bild
sich anguckt sieht man auch dass er
total
weg geblendet wird und ich dann durch
dieses zusätzliche licht einigermaßen
normal erfasst werde ja und das gefühl
dass ich hatte war damals unschön also
ich fühlte mich irgendwie
ausgeschlossen und nicht gesehen nicht
gesehen trifft es genau ob durch
altmodische passbildautomaten moderne
gesichtserkennung oder infrarot
technologie nicht weiße menschen werden
laut forschung schlechter erkannt
programmierte ungerechtigkeit
beeinträchtigt das leben vieler menschen
aber sie kann auch zur gefahr werden für
gesundheit und sogar das leben
mein name ist sehr wehtun ich arbeite
hier am berliner institut auf herz dass
es ein institut der charité
professorin für digitale medizin und
interoperabilität und befasse mich mit
informationstechnologien also mit der
digitalisierung der medizin wie
medizinische algorithmen frauen
benachteiligen erklärt sie uns anhand
von symptomen jagger apps hier kann man
seine symptome eingeben und die apps
sagen einem was man am besten tun soll
da hängt auch ein ki und dann sagt mir
die app danach welche diagnose ich habe
oder ob ich jetzt mich ganz schnell ins
krankenhaus begeben soll oder mich
lieber aufs sofa setzen soll wenn ich
schwierigkeiten habe und da ist
tatsächlich es herausgefunden worden
dass männer die empfehlung bekommen ins
krankenhaus zu gehen bei den gleichen
symptomen diese eingeben wie frauen ja
die bei frauen sagt tomczyk
dass sie sich besser aus und sollen es
kommt daher weil die zugrunde liegenden
daten meistens in der forschung aus
klinischen studien kommen und in diesem
zulassungsstudien nun hat man in erster
linie junge männer warum ist das so weil
frauen natürlich ein gewisses risiko
in einer rennt haben dass sie schwanger
werden könnten es gibt ja viel mehr
hormonelle schwankungen auch die
vielleicht studienergebnisse dann
verfällt und
dementsprechend haben wir eher männer in
den studien aus den studien generieren
wir daten also daten von männern die
dann als grundlage für die algorithmen
benutzt werden ich werde als frau
meistens über therapiert ja weil auf
basis der datenlage ja letztendlich die
dosierung zum beispiel für einen mann
ausgerechnet worden ist und nicht für
eine frau die das natürlich hoch
gefährlich ja also wir könnten sogar bis
das könnte sogar hingehen bis zu einem
tod durch oberst sie herum noch mal
falsch programmierte algorithmen können
im schlimmsten fall zum tod führen
eigentlich unfassbar
wir wollen von cancer abu wissen wie
diese schieflage bei den algorithmen
zustande kommt
männlich weiß dominiert das sind weder
spanisch unterbesetzt ist als trauen
2020 lag der frauenanteil in der
it-branche in deutschland bei 17,5
prozent noch weniger frauen arbeiten in
der branche eine auswertung des
weltwirtschaftsforums zusammen mit dem
berufs netzwerk linkedin aus dem jahr
2018 zeigt in deutschland sind nur 16
prozent aller kg arbeiter innen weiblich
und der rest ist männlich der
algorithmen wälder von menschen
geschrieben alles was mit menschen zu
tun hat ist nicht neutral das ist immer
subjektiv nein weil jeder mensch
vorlieben hat jeder mensch eine
vorgeschichte hat der verzerrungen hat
die er dann widerspiegelt und das wird
in den daten erfasst und die wirken
oftmals unbemerkt viele opfer von
digitaler diskriminierung können selbst
gar nicht nachvollziehen warum ein gerät
oder ein prozess im internet nicht
funktioniert das ich opfer von
technischer oder digitaler
diskriminierung bin es einfach unfassbar
für mich ich habe wie gesagt vorher mir
nie darüber gedanken gemacht weil es
einfach hingenommen habe aber das ist
wirklich eine plausible erklärung dafür
gibt dass das so ist ist für mich
einfach nur ding was ich erstmal
begreifen muss ich finds ungerecht und
es geht mir einfach nicht rein
ist eines der größten probleme gerade
bei der automatisierung in der
fachsprache wird da auch manchmal von
opfer loser diskriminierung gesprochen
was wir aber für sehr problematisch
halten weil natürlich der eindruck
entsteht hier wird diskriminiert aber es
gibt keine opfer was soll das denn nein
es soll halt bezeichnen dass es schwer
ist die opfer zu identifizieren konkret
matthias spielkamp setzt sich schon
lange dafür ein dass algorithmen und
automatisierte prozesse überprüft werden
er ist gründer der ngo al gore watch
seit 2017 klären er und seine
kolleginnen über digitales unrecht auf
und helfen menschen die von digitaler
diskriminierung betroffen sind das war
ja auch unsere idee zu sagen wir machen
jetzt eine anlaufstelle
wo sich menschen melden können und dann
schauen wir mal wie viele menschen das
problem haben und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass menschen auch wenn sie das
gefühl haben ok es betrifft mich jetzt
nicht so doll vielleicht muss ich das
gar nicht melden es ist unheimlich
wichtig das einfach mal zu tun denn das
hilft uns zu quantifizieren wie groß das
problem eigentlich ist
anna lena schiller betreut die plattform
unding hier können sich betroffene
melden die unterstützung brauchen weil
sie durch digitale systeme benachteiligt
werden das kann die facebook plattform
sein bei der es um kommentare und das
ranking von inhalten geht bis hin zur
schufa die auf automatisierten prozessen
basierend eben versucht leuten die zum
bewährten dazu wie kreditwürdig sie sind
auch denn hätte sich theoretisch an
unding wenden können von uns erfährt sie
von der plattform und bekommt
erklärungen warum einen seifenspender
nicht auslöste oder eine tür nicht
aufging infrarot technologie zum
beispiel reagiert auf licht reflexionen
auf der haut und löst aus wenn ein
vorprogrammierter grenzwert
überschritten wird der dunkle haut
weniger licht reflektiert als helle wird
dieser grenzwert nicht überschritten und
so kann es passieren dass ein
seifenspender nicht auslöst oder eine
tür nicht aufgeht anna lena schiller
berichtet auch von den problemen mit
automaten für biometrische passbilder
die mit gesichtserkennung funktionieren
die erklärung die die leute bekommen
haben ist das nicht gut genug
ausgeleuchtet wir basteln hemer ein
bisschen an dicht aber was
wahrscheinlich ist dass die grundlage
also was sind eigentlich für
beispielfotos eingespeist wurden für die
gesichtserkennung hauptsächlich
hellhäutige menschen waren und das
einfach die datengrundlage bei schwarzen
menschen nicht groß genug waren man kann
also daten ganz gleich ob bei
gesichtserkennung oder algorithmen fair
programmieren aber das geschieht oft
nicht
für mich war eine der prägnantesten
geschichten die bei der wir
stellenanzeigen veröffentlicht haben in
dem einen fall wurden lkw fahrerinnen
und lkw fahrer gesucht in dem anderen
fall pflegerinnen und pfleger und es hat
sich dann herausgestellt dass ohne dass
wir ausgewählt haben selber welchen
zielgruppen die angezeigt werden sollten
ganz klar war dass ein großteil
derjenigen die die stellenanzeigen für
pfleger innen gesehen haben frauen waren
und einen großteil derjenigen die die
stellenanzeigen für lkw fahrer innen
gesehen haben männer waren und das zeigt
eben einfach sehr klar dass da schon ein
neues also ein vorurteil im system
steckt
der algorithmus hat also aus der
vergangenheit gelernt welcher beruf eher
zu männern und welche er zu frauen passt
die leute fühlen sich wirklich hilflos
und die kommen in so einer art
teufelskreis aus dem sinn ich wieder
rauskommen
unsicherheit wenn nicht sogar angst
konnte der deutsche tüv in einer umfrage
feststellen
42 prozent der deutschen machen sich
große sorgen dass ki diskriminierend ist
und sogar 71 prozent haben angst davor
dass ki verwendet wird um menschen zu
manipulieren
wer sitzt eigentlich an der spitze der
tech unternehmen
[Musik]
die meisten big player der
software-entwicklung kommen aus den usa
und china als deutsches unternehmen ist
der sap marktführer und der größte
hersteller von unternehmenssoftware
die industrie muss in anspruch genommen
werden weil es muss ihnen klar sein dass
wählen sie einen datensatz nutzen dass
es sehr wahrscheinlich ist dass er die
unwahrheit unserer gesellschaft in sich
trägt viele unternehmen haben
verzerrungen in ihren algorithmen nicht
alle sind sich darüber bewusst und nicht
alle kann man deutlich an klagen denn
die algorithmen sind gut gehütete
betriebsgeheimnisse aber manchen schon
häufig unter kritik stehen social media
plattformen sie beziehen ihre codes
nicht von software herstellern sondern
programmieren ihre eigenen algorithmen
unternehmen wie meter dazu gehören
facebook instagram und whatsapp steuern
bewusst springen wir noch mal
zurückziehen facebook files die frances
horgen gelegt hat aus diesem geht hervor
dass sich facebook mitarbeiter innen
bewusst darüber sind dass zum beispiel
schwarze menschen wie denn durch
algorithmen benachteiligt werden
facebook hat mit ziemlich großem aufwand
mit vielen klugen leuten die da drauf
geguckt haben versucht zu erkennen wo
probleme entstehen auf der eigenen
plattform und sie haben da interessante
entdeckung gemacht und was haben sie mit
den entdeckungen getan sie haben sie
ignoriert und ich finde dann ist das
absolut gerechtfertigt und überhaupt
nicht unfair zu sagen ja sie stellen
einfach ihre gewinninteressen über
gleichbehandlung über zivilität auf der
plattform über die rechte von
betroffenen
laut algorithmen watch ergreift
maßnahmen um forscher innen daran zu
hindern herauszufinden wie auf dem
plattform inhalte gemacht und gesteuert
werden
und schlussendlich hat facebook dann
tatsächlich großen druck auf uns
ausgeübt hat gesagt wenn wir dieses
letzte daten spende projekt was wir zur
bundestagswahl in deutschland gemacht
haben nicht beenden dann wird es eben
schärfere durchsetzung maßnahmen von
ihrer seite geben eine sprecherin von
meter weist die anschuldigungen von
algorithmen watch entschieden zurück
als unternehmen haben wir ein
geschäftliches und moralisches interesse
daran dass die menschen gute erfahrung
auf facebook und in zu machen aus diesem
grund ergreifende maßnahmen um die
sicherheit der menschen zu schützen auch
wenn dies auswirkungen auf unser
geschäftsergebnis hat
außerdem erklärt uns die meta sprecherin
wie viel aufwand das us unternehmen
betreibt um sicherheit und schutz der
nutzer in zu gewährleisten
ganz klar ist aber dass gerade bei den
großen plattformen wie etwa facebook es
gibt keinen wirklich konkurrierende
social network dazu dass die natürlich
eine besonders große verantwortung haben
und es ist völlig offensichtlich dass
sie dieser verantwortung nicht gerecht
werden und wenn das der fall ist dann
muss man sich natürlich fragen wie kann
man sie dazu zwingen und dann kommt
schlussendlich der gesetzgeber ins spiel
[Musik]
mein name ist amazon bin
bundestagsabgeordnete aus frankfurt am
main bin seit
2021 im bundestag mit dem ausschuss für
digital ist und setzte mich unter
anderem mit dem thema digitalisierung
nachhaltigkeit und auch ethische
standards digitalisierung wir haben den
digital services becken dem titel format
direkt und mit dem effekt haben wir drei
große gesetzespakete die auf dem weg
sind und jeder fühlt dazu führen werden
dass unser leben in der digitalen welt
besser wird sicherer wird eine
europaweite regelung für den einsatz
künstlicher intelligenz wird derzeit im
rahmen des digital service eks
beschlossen diese sieht vor ki system
die als klare bedrohung für die
sicherheit die lebensgrundlagen und die
rechte der menschen gelten werden
verboten verstöße mit massiven
geldstrafen sanktioniert dass zukünftig
unternehmens selbst bewerten müssen ob
die algorithmen die sie entwickeln ob
dann hohes risiko ein hohes risiko oder
diskriminierung damit verbunden ist dann
ist es schon mal ein schritt nach vorne
nichtsdestotrotz finde ich schade und
das ist meine kritik an dem vorhaben
dass mein unternehmen dieser
entscheidung überlässt war ich glaube
das ist entscheidung die us gesellschaft
treffen sollten und wir brauchen da eine
unabhängige kontrolle weil ich da kein
vertrauen habe zwei oder sogar drei
jahre soll es nach meinung von
algorithmen watch dauern bis die
auswirkungen zu spüren sind und deswegen
müssen wir warten piste prozess
abgeschlossen ist wenn man kann relativ
man kann nicht vollkommen erwarten dass
ein gesetz all diese ethischen und
sozialen probleme abdeckt aber wir haben
den ersten schritt gemacht wir haben
beschlossen dass wir algorithmen nicht
frei herumlaufen lassen beamten sondern
wir haben uns für entschlossene
regelungen
zu schreiben an die sich alle halten
müssen
in ihrer forschungsgruppe governance of
emerging technologies kurz kit
entwickelte sie mehrere tests die wie
eine art alarmanlage bei unethischen
algorithmen funktionieren das haben
eigentlich schon viele unternehmen
gemacht also unsere experimente tools
werden zum beispiel von google genutzt
von ibm accenture und wurde von unser
bayers test wird jetzt von amazon
eingesetzt also die großen technik
unternehmen haben auch gesehen dass da
ein wert für ihre eigene klientel ist
algorithmen fairer und offener zu
gestalten gibt es noch weitere
positivbeispiele ja die gibt es 1 kommt
von mozilla mit einer frau an der
unternehmensspitze wir haben zum
beispiel für die spracherkennung
möglichst viele sprach beispiele
gesammelt da gibt es eine seite namens
kommen und da kann man das knopf drücken
und seine eigene stimme aufnehmen und
das ist dann die datengrundlage für die
weitere spracherkennung und so macht man
natürlich die tür viel viel weiter auf
als wenn man sagt wir sind jetzt ein
großes tech unternehmen wir lagen uns
100 leute ein und die sprechen dass ein
und das ist unsere datengrundlage ok
habe verstanden
letztendlich geht es darum die zukunft
zu gestalten und vieles kann man
versuchen durch prozessen und gesetzen
und so zu erzwingen aber vieles passiert
auch automatisch einfach durch die
unterschiedliche besetzungen also man
kann nicht nur sagen so jetzt sind die
frauen in der führungsposition jetzt
werden die algorithmen gut das war
passiert nicht automatisch aber dadurch
dass vielleicht eine frau in einer
führungsposition von einem erfolgreichen
start-up ist achtet sie mehr darauf dass
jemand noch mal hinterfragt
und was wünschen sich jen und tanja dass
er ich glaube für viele menschen ganz
unglaubliche heilung so wird das man
sich irgendwo wieder findet dass man mit
dazu gehört dass man sich nicht aus
leipzig fühlt und irgendwie anders also
für die zukunft wünsche ich mir einfach
das schwarze menschen gesehen werden
dass wir angenommen werden und dass wir
gleichwertig behandelt werden von dem
algorithmus noch nicht ausgeschlossen
werden ich glaube tatsächlich dass die
algorithmen der spiegel
unsere gesellschaft ist und wir stehen
hier vor großen entscheidungen und zu
überlegen was mit diesem spiel mitmachen
wollen wollen wir uns weg dahin und zu
tun ist würden wir es nicht sehen oder
wollen sie es ernst nehmen und es so zu
sagen dass eine to do list sehen aber um
verhalten liegen und dann anfangen
richtig dafür sorge zu tragen dass
vereine zur verfügung kommt fest steht
diskriminierung lässt sich nicht eben
mal die programmieren damit künstliche
intelligenz unserer vorurteile nicht
mehr übernimmt verstärkt und fest
schreibt müssen wir erstmal bei uns
anfangen und unsere vorurteile und
fragen stellen
dann haben wir die chance auf eine
menschliche zukunft auch in der
digitalen welt
[Musik]